so welcome everyone after the break it's
a great pleasure for me to introduce our
next speaker so that's a
perfect coincidence because you know
after lunch we're full but now we have
something exciting so definitely we'll
be waking up
so it's a great pleasure to pass the
microphone to jennifer chase from
berkeley here who is the main organizer
of this event thank you
yes i'm a delinquent maine organizer of
this event um
so
anyway thank you for being here on you
know
friday afternoon of memorial day weekend
uh
some of you are gonna know this some of
you are gonna see me give a lot of these
slides some of you won't have seen me
give these so uh so anyway let me get
started
so
i'm i'm gonna
very quickly review a couple of things
that christian talked about in his first
three lectures
dense graph convergence
and
convergence for sparse graphs of unbound
of a bounded um a bounded degree but
what i
really am going to concentrate on
is sparse graphs of unbounded degrees so
you know things like power law graphs
and other graphs that don't have
a bound
on the number of nearest neighbors
but and and are and are sparse
uh so we'll talk about convergence
for those graphs
then
we'll talk about uh
having a function a graph on
corresponding to those graphs such that
if we um
we we can use it to generate realization
samples
of that kind of graph
then i'll talk a little bit about
learning how we estimate
those kinds of graphs so if i
if i had
something that i was
measuring
you know how would i estimate what the
corresponding graph on is
and uh
and we'll also talk about that for uh
uh um to do that in a privacy preserving
way for smaller class of graphs
and then i'll give an
application of this okay
and stop me with any questions that you
have along the way i'm not gonna take
you through proofs like christian did
although i will try to help you
understand where some of this stuff is
is coming from
okay so um
i i know that christian had this this
picture i always like to start out i
mean i assume that most of you here
know graphs and you know adjacency
matrices and that kind of thing but
okay so we have a graph like the half
graph over there
and
um i can you know take all the vertices
of the graph put it on two sides of my
adjacency matrix and if you know i is
connected to j i'm gonna color it in
black
and if it's not i'm gonna leave it white
and so
there's um the adjacency matrix of the
half graph
and then i'm gonna
you know heuristically take a limit okay
so what you know uh just how would that
look as things got finer and finer with
larger and larger graphs of that form
similarly for the random graph
let's say that p equals one-half
or this rendering graph
i'm going to get
you know a kind of a a grayscale
limit
um
and then of course there's a question
about what about permutation of the
vertices okay these
these two graphs um you know i can
permute the vertices of one graph to get
the other graph
um
[Music]
those weird limits don't look the same
actually they look
looks like they're going to look very
different
and
the fact that
for exchangeable graphs they're
invariant under
invariant under permutations
like
this in the limiting
image that you get you have an even
larger invariance
the invariance is in variance under
measure preserving bijections
maps that are one-to-one and onto okay
but that's just a reflection of the
permutation invariance that you're
really comfortable with for a finite
graph or a finite exchangeable graph
and so with christian and watsi lovas
back in
2010
actually most of our work a lot of it is
way before it was published because we
take forever to get our papers done as
some people have tried to work with us
no
but this
limiting this graphon that corresponds
to the graph is unique up to measure
preserving bijections
in my carp lecture i'm going to talk
about graffixes
and
they're the
the corresponding
the corresponding thing that we have to
mod out by to get a unique one
is much much larger and interestingly we
did that with lotsy lovas
jr
many many years later as a birthday
present to lotsy lovas senior
on a big birthday and it was over a
hundred pages so it was really ugly
in some sense but also really satisfying
and that was matsilovas's
senior's present
okay
so um
so christian also told you about
dense graph
convergence
so the one that you really want to get
your hands on because you can prove
things with it
is
metric
convergence so we came up with something
called the cut metric that harpen
harkens back to what freeze and conning
did
in
1999
they looked at a given graph
and they said what is the max cut
through that
given graph so just imagine i didn't
have a w1 and a w2 i just had a w in
there
and i asked
and and t were equal to s complement
what is the largest cut i could
take through that graph okay um so you
know which which edges
uh
would i would i be cutting okay
and that
gave me some
some kind of a measure for that graph
so then what we did was we said
let us take
the
rathons
the
these limiting objects that correspond
to those two graphs
okay if they don't
you know so we we assume that they're on
the same space now
and
i wanna
maximize the
cut distance between them but again i
must
take the if overall measure preserving
bijections because it can look
different depending on what measure
preserving by bijection i use so i so i
use the one which gives me the inf of
all of those and i say that that's the
distance so that's your very concrete
analytical object that you use
to prove things about all these other
ones okay
this is all for dense graphs so we came
up with more and in fact one that i i'm
sorry i'm not mentioning with david
garnick but maybe
christian
mentioned it i don't know but we
one slide where it showed up okay
although i do have your name on one of
on one of my next slide okay but
we came up with what we called left or
local convergence
so why did we call it left
we called it left because
we thought of
christian might have told you this but
you know
we thought of a big graph g
homomorphisms into a little graph h
so i take my
big graph
and i i mean i can
map it into something really small like
h could be an edge okay
oh my god
so what we're doing is let me take my
big round teeth and map it into an edge
okay
let me take my big graph g and map it
into a triangle
let me take my big graph g
and map it into a four cycle or a
peterson graph or any
finite graph you can think of okay
and i could i mean it's like homozygous
transformations and stuff but it's the
same thing
as looking at
what is what is the frequency
of edges in this big graph g what is the
frequency of triangles or four cycles of
peterson graphs okay
and now i have a whole sequence of
graphs
and i ask
you know let me look as as this sequence
of graphs gets bigger let me look at the
um
the the density of all those finite
graphs
and i ask that all those densities
converge that seems like a pretty local
thing because you know you're looking at
the
right at
these these tiny
tiny graphs right at these tiny things
and you're asking that all of them
converge
and then christian also talked about
sampling convergence
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
just going to go in and i'm going to
sample
k points
randomly out of my graph i'm going to do
this on g1 or t23
and
i'm going to look for the probability
that
h is an induced subgraph there that the
edge is an induced subgraph of these of
these points or
you know a triangle or whatever is the
induced subgraph okay
and i'm going to ask that all of those
converge
okay and actually i think
first place this appeared for dense
graphs was diaconas and johnson i think
um
the other ones here all came from
okay whenever you see a b and you will
always see it in in a set of names uh
it's christian boards
when you see a c
it'll be me when you see two c's it'll
be me and henry cohen
i think
well
um
the the l will either be
well most of the time here it'll be big
love might be younger lovas okay
um
s is shoji veera shoge who
i think of as the grand
dom
of discrete mathematics she's amazing
and kathy vestergambi who is also
amazing
and uh
actually
happens to be married to lotsy and the
mother of lotsy junior okay so we did a
whole series of papers with them
and so
but this thing actually i think i saw
first in diaconas
statistical physics since christian and
i come from that world
uh for us it was a very natural thing to
say
i am given
this graph
and on it
i am going to compute for example the
ground state energy so what i'm going to
do is i have a certain model
and this model says you know there's a
certain weight
of so let's say that you know that i
have two colors up and down
okay you know we don't normally think
about the damage colors but they could
be and uh
and you know what is the weight of an up
being next to a down what is the weight
of end up being next to an up or down
being next to a down okay
for these two colors so now
the sigma is just you know
configurations of every spin up or down
or it could be configurations if i have
20 colors of all these possible things
and and i have these js fixed
and
for dense graphs i divide through by the
volume squared of the graph
and i can calculate a ground state
energy given this model
on
this graph and i can calculate that same
energy
on graph g2 and graph g3 and j graph
gi
and you know
and i ask that those converge
those are actually
um
[Music]
not
they're they're pretty closely related
in a lot of ways
to multi-weight cuts that you might do
in
that you might do more in computer
science where you ask about cuts through
the graph and you know what are the cost
of these
large cuts through through the graph and
you look at the sequence of those
and so
those things will converge on this
sequence and so it turns out that for
dense graph sequences and let me just
yeah
is there a way to think of the right
convergence as
some kind of approximate convergence
exact
example
okay
actually that was that was precisely
what we were doing that's why we thought
of it as right and left that's precisely
what we're doing we're taking
you know
we're
we're taking some graph
here which which actually kind of
represents a color
okay
and we're we're asking what's the
homomorphism of that coloring a set of
rules of who gets connected to who and
with what weight
okay so so i can have you know um
red
yellow blue green okay and i have a
graph that represents oh if blue is
connected to green it has this weight
and if blue is connected to yellow or
red it has those weights and so on so
four choose two
possible weights and i'm taking that
small graph and i'm mapping it into
and taking a big graph and i'm mapping
it into these colorings and that's kind
of what this guy is doing okay so it's
precisely the way to think
you might say the form of this is not a
minimum
but there are tools and configurations
and in this dance technique
it's sort of so in the end that is all
which will survive
okay so it is precisely that
so
it turns out that metric convergence is
equivalent to these
apparently
local and apparently very global
things okay and it's all really nice and
of course dense graphs are graphs where
the number of edges scales like n
squared okay
you know you have a positive fraction of
all possible edges so you have basically
you know a a positive fraction of
positive edges in the
not
non-non-zero
possibilities in the complete graph okay
on those endpoints
okay
so now
let's do that okay
so now sparse graphs of boundary degree
that's a very very different
situation okay so
we actually looked at um
that with lots and with jeff kahn and
then later in some of our stuff on
something called large deviations
convergence with david which is really
really cool but i don't have time to go
into it here we also looked at
kind of at
when you might
see this kind of thing now christian
talked to you about benjamini sram
convergence which long predated
these things so what benjamini sram
convergence is is that i choose a random
vertex so you're you're going to need
this in your talks
oh you talked yesterday okay
it's our anniversary and so
on our 29th anniversary i am a croning
jewel
okay so um
so
benjaminish ram convergence i'm going to
choose a random vertex and i'm going to
look at
graphs
rooted at that random vertex so i might
have a big graph and i look at graphs
that are rooted at that random vertex
and i ask and that's a very very
local notion okay
and so that makes sense for graphs of
bounded degree you know i have no more
than 29 neighbors in this entire graph
okay
um
so subgraph convergence
turns out so so convergence of edges
triangles blah blah turns out to be the
same as that
and then
convergence of free energies is a
strictly stronger notion
is what i call the low temperature phase
of that
model with the colors okay
and
convergence that we're not learning
about with david large deviations
convergence
is strictly stronger all the time okay
um
so
you know these are these are much more
fragile okay i i think of them really as
much more brittle in a way than um
graphs of unbounded
degree
okay so let's think of unbounded degree
graphs so there's you know there's a
very simple one i take the
british renie random graph so i have
n vertices and each pair yeah
between
local conversions of videos
is that just a definition or no that's a
theorem that's the theorem that's what
we proved using cluster expansions
with jeff cummins
as a left convert to this subgraph it's
conversation
how often do i see a triangle you divide
by n yeah
and this is by some inclusion exclusion
well yeah
it's
okay
so
i'm gonna say and we all know i hope
that the random graph means
at density p
means
that you know uh
the probability that any given pair of
the entries two possible pairs is
connected to each other with density p
and so what if p
scale
what if
p
is going to n as n is is going to zero
as n is going
to to infinity so you know we often talk
about the one over n
you know uh random graph so that will
you know then have
you know
something like
uh n squared over n about n connections
in it but that could also be some other
power it need not be one over n
okay
anything which goes to zero
so i
so it could be for example uh
you know
log star
you know whatever log star in it could
go to zero really really slowly
and that would still be unbound and
unbounded to degrade random graph
okay then we have stochastic block
models okay so
the regular stochastic block model has k
colors
and we have something which specifies
that
color
you know i is connected to color j with
um
with density beta i j which is the same
as beta j i because it's an undirected
graph so reds and blues reds and reds
whatever
um
and and i'm going to put a
p in front of that so that i can scale
it
so so what i have here is i have uh so
i'm also specifying here um
the amount of red the amount of blue the
amount of green the amount of yellow and
that should add up to one the density of
red green blue and yellow
and um and i'm going to connect any pair
with that probability
and i'm going to say that the p that i'm
scaling everything by
is going to
uh
is is going to 0 as n goes to infinity
okay so then i can also generate
um
[Music]
you know
a graph which has unbounded
degree okay
i can scale it like one over n and then
i get a graph that has a border
n
edges that i could scale in different
ways going to zero
okay
then i could also do
a fixed i mean these are simpler than
the general case a fixed um a fixed
degree sequence
so
they're kind of getting harder as we go
down this
easier thing
um
so i have d1 up through dn
okay
and what i'm gonna do it so so every
you know uh
every point is coming in with its with
its d and i'm going to connect inj
so i has degree
3 and j has degree 34
and i'm going to connect them with a
probability that looks like 3 times 34
over the sum of all the d's okay
and if i scale this
in some way
for example if i say that
d i looks like some fixed
n to the alpha
times
n over i to the beta
then what happens is this this gives me
the probability that um d is bigger than
some k times n to the alpha and it turns
into a power law
in
k
with
beta being beta is is positive here okay
so i can get a power law out of a fixed
degree sequence if i have
degrees that are of this form okay
and so the question is in general
develop a theory of sparse graph
convergence
which includes these examples
you know in in particular
allowing for power laws but much more
general examples too okay very general
examples
okay
so
um what's the problem with this if we
try to just blindly go and do what we
did before for dense graphs
um
you know edge density
is
you know um
the the number of edges over the number
of vertices squared okay
and this
goes to zero okay so the the the cut
norm
of um
of of this
is bounded above by the one norm which
is the density so so this is going to go
to zero so everything works but it works
really trivially okay all my all my
limiting
[Music]
graph ons are zero it's not wrong it's
just not interesting in any way
okay
so
you know what if i i mean
this is at least
you know this is
similar to the first
thing we thought of doing
so you know what i want to do is i want
to
let's say i want to normalize it right i
want to normalize it so that the
probability that these uh
that you know that these uh k points
that i choose is some fixed graph h how
would i think i should normalize that
well i should normalize it by
one over the density to the number of
edges okay and that you would think
would would help you okay
and the only problem with that is that
it's just way too brittle okay
so um
so if i had like
p
okay so if i had
p goes like n to the minus two thirds
okay
then
um then let's think about that let me
look at an edge okay
there are
n
possible
so i'm going to look at an edge
and an edge
so so this vertex is here
with there are n possibilities for this
vertex
there are n minus one let's call that n
possibilities for that vertex okay
and then the probability of this is p
goes like n to the minus
two thirds so that's n squared
times
um times
n to the minus two thirds so it it has n
to the four thirds edges okay
now how many triangles does it have
well
triangles that it has are
okay so
um
so i have
n
n minus 1 and minus 2 that's n
times
uh what did we say
n to the minus two thirds
uh
cubed okay and and so what what happens
is that i get only n triangles okay
and so what i could do
is i can remove all the triangles
without removing
you know
with removing essentially none of the
edges little o of one of the edges and
so
anything like this is not gonna work
okay it's just too
too brittle
to to do that
okay
so
what we did instead
was two things and i'll give you and
henceforth when i when i talk about
sparse graphs i'm always going to be
talking about sparse graphs of unbounded
degree okay i just
i don't have to say and bound to degree
every time but i'm not
talking about a bounded sparse graph
um
okay so
one idea
is
um
instead of
dividing here by v squared
okay n squared
as i did
for for dense graphs
i divide through by the number
of um
by the number of edges in the graph at
least i'll get something which is not
zero then
um and another thing
is that
i'm going to modify
my left
[Music]
sampling convergence as follows
instead of sampling
k points i'm going to let
k scale i'm going to say i'm going to
sample plus on t over square root of rho
many vertices from v okay so i'm
you know and and and and rho is going to
zero okay and so i'm sampling more and
more and more to compensate for the fact
that otherwise it would be disappearing
and so the expected number of edges
that i sample is k squared times rho
over 2
and this gives an expected number of
edges which is uniform so i'm trying to
so i'm compensating for that
and
then i'm going to remove all isolated
vertices and return the induced subgraph
and we call this rescale sampling
convergence now these two
turn out to be
equivalent
to something else that i'm now going to
tell you about okay
which
looks more like a metric and metrics are
good because we can prove things when we
have a metric
so
goldmash and reardon did this for w's
and l infinity so bounded w's
and then with um
henry cohen and you fee zhao you just
got published much later as when we did
them um
we did this in a in a more general sense
so we said what i'm going to do for my
graph on
is the the the graph would be going to
zero okay
and so what i want to do instead is i
want to divide through
by one over that zero density
okay
and so what i'm doing so just think
about our unit square here
and uh
what i had before for a dense graph was
kind of nice finite things there and
when i divide through by something going
to zero okay these are going to get very
big
okay so these heights are going to get
very big
and and then i'm going to define
a rescaled metric
which is the difference between
this
rescale thing where i've divided through
by this density that's going to zero and
my limiting w so in particular my
limiting w was going to be unbounded
okay it's going to be on the unit square
but it's going to be unbounded okay so
that's a different thing
we were always seeing bounded w's in the
dense case
okay
and
it turns out
what what you have to do is you have to
prevent
mass from leaking out to infinity
and so we came up with a regularity
condition
which we called
uniform
uniform regularity in which we basically
said that the
you know
the the probability that
w is bigger than something as we get
bigger and bigger and bigger is
controllable okay
so that math doesn't actually leak away
we first did this in general
using like an lp
metric and then we realized oh if you
have an lp for all p you actually get
this uniform
regularity so
okay so we said if mass is not running
up to infinity here then we're in good
shape
and that turns out to be the same thing
as taking the
ground state energy
and instead of dividing through by n
squared divide through by the number of
edges which coincided with n squared in
the case of a dense graph
but not in the case of a sparse graph
and using these kind of new metrics with
the rescale graphons we were able to
prove things about that
jennifer i have a more silly question
it's an odd plus as the image of the
potential image of the w
can't you do something more so that it's
just a compact
compact interval
which is not just a zero one because you
are re-normalizing it
not just so so the the
w yeah can sit on it it need not sit on
a compact center hole but
there's no
you know but but it's it's sitting on
what were you saying so the limit is not
compact you can't
oh that's what she's asking you're
asking about a completion no no it is
not compact
okay it's not compact and that
and that is why i mean
otherwise you could just get a subs easy
subsequent limits and you'd be like in
great shape okay
all the warriors
yes that's what bailey and oliver did
and so theirs then had to be bounded it
had to be on infinity
and
in this case you don't get in in our
case you don't get subsequential limits
so where bella and oliver j normalize it
by
l infinity node
no but they are able to
get it they are able to compactify it
if w turns out to be l infinity they're
able to get sequential limits with no
further restrictions because the mass is
not leaking out children
so you take this picture
right right okay risk it right
so just like this here it goes to
infinity and then and now your graph
becomes finer and finer you get sort of
higher higher towers and an empty
manhattan there's a lot of empty space
and now they put a condition that if you
integrate over any
weird notion so it's bounded if it stays
integrated over a small region it's one
reason where the
so what is the condition the condition
is
so you fix some constancy and then you
take for any epsilon yeah you can sort
of choose
if you put groups where you don't have
less than epsilon and vertices
then the average performance is bounded
so it turns out
so they are only doing it for bounded
grounds it turns out okay and we said no
let us not what if they call that you
know some kind of spot no
no dead spots okay and but of course
most of the ones we care about have
these dead spots so then
to get the subsequential limits because
we didn't have the compactness by
something like that
we had to do a lot more work and we
showed finally that you could do that
lp for all p
and therefore
uniform if if they were uniformly
regular if the probability that the
that that these these graphics that
are greater than whatever
does not run off
too quickly okay then you're fine
okay and that is and that is how we got
it but you know it allows
w being l1 l2 and l27
uniformly ready
okay
um
okay
now
think about doing something totally
different okay how do i make sense of
this
the other thing that i could do
is i could
instead of dividing through by w
i could change my metric
okay and so what i'm doing is i'm
stretching so i'm no longer sitting in
on the unit square i'm stretching
the underlying metric by square root of
this w which by the way remember this is
going to zero okay
so i'm stretching it
by that okay
and
so
what you land up half so we call this
now the rescaled
w okay so what we're doing is we're
we're playing with the underlying metric
okay
and and remember this is you know so so
now i get more and more and more and
more and more points right because i'm
because i'm not right
and that
turns out
that to be
equivalent in many many cases and i will
and and if we modify that a tiny bit in
all cases
to
um
to the sampling
where you sample with a poisson
that makes you go further and further
and further out
according to square root of rho
okay so
this is equivalent to a modified version
of left convergence under suitable
regularity conditions
and maybe i'll define it later in this
lecture maybe i'll define it in
in
my carp lecture i don't remember
okay and the stretch graph on
can be generated via a projective
process
on graph so this is me christian henry
cohn and victor veich
and
it turns out to correspond to something
that victor and dan roy had done a few
years earlier defining something called
a graphics okay but
we can do that just so so i'll tell you
there's this distinction graphicses and
graphons that i won't talk about now but
i'll talk about in the carp lecture
okay
but the nice thing about this let me
just say well you'll you'll see it here
um actually
so
without extra technical conditions mass
can disappear
you know
up to infinity or
and and so we don't get subsequential
convergence for arbitrary sequences
except
you know
so that we have to apply this this
condition
um
so as i said we develop these notions of
regularity
uniformly regular tails or uniform upper
regularity
can we get a sequence which converges in
both senses the rescaled one and the
stretched one
and what sparsity can we achieve and the
answer is and this is with nina holden
and henry cohn um
if both
of those converge then it turns out that
g is actually dense okay so those are
really
different kinds of situations
okay
and uh if either of those but not both
converge then
g oh no if either of those converge then
it has divergent
average
degrees
okay so the advantages of the first that
scaling
you can get sparse power law graphs it's
equivalent to right convergence or
multi-way cuts under this assumption of
uniform upper regularity
and the advantages of stretching it
gives convergence with very long power
law tails
the notion of left convergence can be
generalized to sparse grass which he did
with henry kona victor veich
and under the assumption of uniform tail
regularity which i didn't really go
through with you it's equivalent to
stretch metric convergence
and then we can also and that i'll
really do in the carb lecture extend the
notion of graphons to something even
bigger which is the completion of
the space of graphons um then we get
compactness and subsequential
convergence without
further conditions
the yeah is selected so that the average
degree
is there right
slightly above this very sparse sparser
yes absolutely but it could grow
you know very slowly yeah
technically
fixed in the graph have unbounded
typically the largest degrees growing
but that's not the reason i'm talking
i'm
a virgin average yeah degree
okay
but jennifer so because we were
we we heard a lot of uh
talks uh from economic
economic works and it seems that they
always assume this uh
this either average degree is low end so
that the graph is connected network is
connected or a
strongly connected
so you need
this new series you need this you're
we wanted this because in applications
you always want
this okay i mean any you know facebook
anything like that i mean they may
actually prohibit you from having more
than a certain number of connections but
in the real world in social interactions
there's no bound
right i mean
but not defense right what but not but
they're not yes exactly but you know
think of i mean
you know
how many people unfortunately want to
connect to wanted to connect to donald
trump on twitter
you know okay
uh
that's what it is okay
[Music]
okay so we've just done this part i have
a lot to do for you i have this part and
this part so now what i'm thinking is
okay so
we're we're actually you you could put
them in a sigma finite
measure space
um
yeah
and
you could have a symmetric measurable
function actually
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take graph funds of that form
and i'm going to use the function to
generate
graphs to generate representative graphs
okay so the traditional approach to
non-parametric graph modeling is to use
the stochastic block model which we've
discussed before right i mean i'm not
saying p times beta here i'm just saying
p alpha beta
um so i'm going to have you know k
colors and i'm going to connect them
according to this symmetric matrix of
probabilities for red rainbow yellow
okay and then if you try to estimate
this
for diverging average degrees
estimating these peas
well how do how does one typically do
that in practice
they first determine
what the group labels are they first
determine you know what the densities of
red blue yellow green are
they use some kind of clustering some
kind of belief propagation i mean that's
not rigorous they were just using that
right and then
average the adjacency matrix over all
edges whose endpoints have colors red
and blue
whatever and they get the model
but
you know what happens if the model
you're measuring is not a block model
nothing comes out of those estimations
to tell you
oh you made the wrong assumption about
the form
of it okay
so it it's not stable under miss
specifications um
so that's not what we want an
alternative
non-parametric approaches in homogeneous
random graphs which actually you know
without proofs goes back to
2002
and then others have have worked on it
and instead of a matrix indexed by
communities
the way i think of this is a function
based on features
so
given a feature space with a probability
distribution pi so what do i mean by
that okay
let's say my features are
my gender
my
height
my
age my weight my
uh final degree the field of my final
degree among some
100 possible fields
the you know
uh
and all these other things about me okay
i mean just so many other things about
me
and uh and so what i want to do is i
want to generate
um
people
points with this set of attributes okay
probably not going to be generating many
with heights above 6 8
okay
so my distribution's gonna the
probability that's gonna be pretty small
if i'm trying to you know if i'm if i'm
trying to
uh to
to generate people and you know they're
probably not gonna be as many degrees in
physics as there are in computer science
and all kinds of things like that so i
have some probability distribution
um so that's generating so i'm going to
choose
these iid according to pi
okay so so
these are points in omega so omega's my
feature space
certainly need not be one-dimensional
okay
it typically is not one-dimensional and
it can include continuous things and i
can include discrete things and whatever
and then i'm going to connect
two points
with and i'm going to scale by the
density appropriately with the
probability that if i have this height
this weight this gender this whatever
um
you know
probability that i connect with
christian is whatever it is we both did
physics and whatever okay
um
and then i'm i'm gonna have to be
scaling it appropriately by a density
which is going to zero because on
facebook or something the density is
right
so
then i'm going to call the resulting
random graph an inhomogeneous random
graph at target density rho n
and denote it by this
so
you know let's just say
you went to facebook you're a new
employee and they handed you
the w and the row n
of facebook okay and now you can start
generating these random graphs right
um
okay so that's
one way of doing it okay
the problem is if i think of a sequence
of graphs here they're not projective
when i go adding yeah
yeah from the christian's uh lecture
whenever we heard about graphon it was
measurable uh-huh and the image space of
graphene was of course zero one now we
extend it to the r plus so still it's
just
and measurable that's it
that's it right and i because my measure
space
my measure space
is
you know
it
and the relation to the res to rescale
convergences
is that um
this thing
converges so
if i take
something generated like this i generate
the
the individuals i generate the
connections from
this thing i handed you
it is going to converge
to the to the function i use to generate
it the the w that that you got when you
walked into facebook there's a new
employee
in the rescaled metric if if row goes to
zero
um but the but
the average degree diverges okay
so this is really corresponding to
what's going on
in your rescale metric okay so they're
true
that what oh my
they're they're true to um
usually when it's calling it's christian
but calling me by mistake
you interrupted the lectures this
morning
may may have been may have been anyway
so that's one thing okay
another totally different approach is
something called a graph on process
so um
this work the first time i ever saw it
was uh corona and fox
in the case of
a w
which was a product
function
okay
so it was like w of x and y was like um
uh
g to the uh g of x times f of y okay so
what it's a rank one case exactly
oh and actually i think well g that's
true because it has to be symmetric okay
so um and then roy invites
also did a generalization of this
although we were the ones who studied
the notion of convergence when we did it
with um
and they studied some beautiful
extensions called graphics's which i
will talk more about later
and this is work we did with uh nina
holden and henry cohen okay so i'm going
to have a a sigma finite measure space
and a graph on
okay
and
now what i'm going to do
is
i'm going to have this
hassan
process of of points that i generate
remember these points are going to be
individuals with heights and ages and
areas they're interested in and you know
uh areas that hey like some of us are
not as big sports fans or whatever so
they're being generated as the points of
a poisson process with intensity t
times mu so mu
is the measure that determines
what these features are likely to be you
know
no
not too many seven
foot
people things like that seven people
okay
and then what i'm going to do
because i've got a
a w i'm gonna connect them with
probability w okay so this is how likely
am i to connect with somebody
of the same gender or a different gender
or this or that or whatever right or you
know an undetermined gender and
um
and then um
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
remove all
isolated vertices and spit out a finite
graph at time t so let me show you how
this works so i have reduced this very
high dimensional space
of
my height my weight my interest my
whatever
to one dimension here
and
this point came out first in my poisson
process and this point came out second
and this point and this is a a
one-dimensional therefore not at all
faithful projection of this very big
space
onto one dimension so they come out here
and then what did i do so these came out
and i flipped my w weighted coins and i
said
okay
x1
try connecting to x2 tails try
connecting to x3 tails try connecting to
export tails
so x1 didn't get connected x2
you flipped it it got connected to x3 it
got connected to x4 but when i flipped
my three four coin nothing happened okay
my w waited three four point okay
what why is the projection important
the projection is not important i'm just
trying to draw it for you
okay
now at time two what has happened
three more points have been born x5 x6
x7 okay
so
x5 oh my x5 they flipped all the ones
and twos and whatever and you know and
nothing nothing attached
but
uh and and then x6 i ended up attaching
to two and four when i flipped my points
but nothing else okay
and then x7 came in and lo and behold it
attached to x1 so now x1 shows up okay
because now all of a sudden
it's not isolated anymore okay so things
can appear when someone attaches to them
okay
so this is some weird process right
and corona and fox did this
in the case w is uh f of x f y
and so
we showed in this paper
that um
the graph on process that you generate
i'm going to get this sequence of graphs
i got a gt1 a gt2 a g right
um
is going to converge to the w
that it was
generated from
in the stretch cut metric okay so in
other words this
this um
the sequence of graphs
is
uh
is um
faithful in that sense to the to the w
it was generated from to the coin flips
it was generated from from that function
how does the stretching work i mean the
stretching
is when you say it converges
is the stretching somehow happening
along the limit or yeah so so actually
you know what i could do and
you know i may talk more about this in
in the heart lecture but
really i should be extending this okay
and what's happening
is that i am
i'm recording these points as they come
up okay as i'm as i'm growing
this thing okay
so
i'm no longer restricting
right and so
um this is
like the graph on process that's
generated so here i have
all my points x1 through
xn
and here i have all my points
and these are appearing
when they
pair with somebody else
okay
and
and so
this is the process that's generated and
that process
converges to
that w
in the stretched metrics
when i take this sequence of graphs
and i just draw this vertices and
stretch it
it looks
to you probably as if i just think
everything out and things get sort of
more and more widely spread right
but remember this is this instrument for
measure
transformations
and once you apply that effectively now
all of the vertices by time
and now if you think in that domain
you sort of have this integral function
and now
this thing's further out will be faster
and faster
and that's why it converges
[Music]
and then the inhomogeneous random graph
will look more like this i'll focus on
the second model and graphics is which i
haven't defined
which were defined by foreign
okay
and so now how do i estimate
so now um
i've seen that if i have a graph a
sequence of graphs i can get a limit
under many circumstances even for sparse
graphs of unbounded degree
and if i'm given a symmetric measurable
function on a sigma finite measure space
which has features
and sigma algebra and uh
and um
a measure on those features okay
uh
then i can generate
representative graphs
now
given a graph given like one sample of a
graph i take a snapshot of a graph
and i ask you can you estimate
what the corresponding graph on is okay
now
i am facebook i take a
snapshot of my graph and i ask you can
you estimate it i can ask you can you
estimate it quickly i don't know how to
do that
but i will ask you can i estimate it
yes
yes and that's why
well okay
no she said it's steph crafton so yes so
the question is how would you do this
okay
and this is work that we did
with trishenda van gohli in like 2015 or
16 but which finally got published
um
it took forever to get referred i mean
it was somehow
i think
uh
so we estimate
what we're going to do
is we're going to estimate w by the best
k block approximation to the adjacency
matrix okay
we're going to use a least squares
algorithm and the reason that we do this
instead of some of the more conventional
ways of doing it is things can explode
actually if you use some other
algorithms
so we're given an input graph with an
adjacency matrix base this is your
snapshot of
facebook or linkedin or something
and an integer okay i'm going to ask you
to get like a k block approximation to
it
and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
find
the best
k
block approximation to it so i'm going
to take my thing a i'm going to um
look at
the matrix b and whenever i look at a
matrix b i'm going to first go over all
uh
all permutations of b
okay
find the minimum one of those
and then i want the b that minimizes
okay so for every b i'm going to pick
the
element of this
equivalence class
that gives me the lowest one
and then i'm going to say okay and now
i'm going to find the best b and the
best
element of the equivalence class
b
and so this is going to run over this is
offices just like to make sure that
they're equal right one image is of
nearly equal sizes yes that's all this
is saying exactly
and
and i'm going to output the empirical
graph on
corresponding to this okay the
you know the the
w that's in blocks basically
and as n tends to infinity
the in this empirical graph on gives the
best block model approximation to w in
the l2 norm
as long as w is in l2
uh
the density is going to zero so it's a
sparse graph but the average density is
blowing up okay
and here this d2 you know it's the
l2 norm of the difference between
the
the um one and all
measure preserving bijections
over the other one okay so we should
probably mention that this algorithm is
not new it was used by several other
people and in the dense case
somebody in the audience
yes it's first case no but you think but
even so in this so first the dance case
took this way
first it was in the dances people showed
that she's bound to get on that
is optimal they max and then she proved
that for the bounded so for bounded
platform
that it's min max optimizes algorithm
and then he gave bounce it's an
unbounded case but we didn't prove it
and it does get a little hearing but i
mean it's what you would hope for
but the the proof it just has to be and
i'm not sure
oh they're they're awful i mean just
think
you know i i think that they're not
optimal
yeah yeah and and of course if you
actually try to do this in practice
but at least you get
you
you know that they are estimatable yes
so i was wondering in the optimizations
that learn how the michigan
that's the choice of the norm
choice of the norms here we choose the
two norm uh we can choose
matrix more but then make the difference
already uh we proved it for the two norm
i think could we do it for other lps
christian
the queens get hairy for the following
reason if you want to minimize it to
know
you differentiate
you get some linear object okay and then
you can take expectations off that and
you can prove concentrations charm up
and so on
if you take another norm like this three
normally you differentiate it's not
linear anymore you don't know how to
calculate the expectations
would you know how to do it in that now
at least for one norm for bounded rough
ones it's quite easy
encounter doesn't make sense because
so now private network estimation
so this was with
me and christian and adam smith
and then um elias um iliac is is he here
in the other program or do you know
anyway
um he
did a real strengthening with us a few
years later which i'll mention
so uh
so you know even for database there's
privacy issues and of course
fork and adam smith and others developed
this
notion of differential privacy because
even even
for for a database you know uh
you know if i take bill gates in or out
of the database that has to do
something with with income year you're
going to notice it okay
privacy problem for graphs is even worse
because connections reveal information
about people for example in 2009
uh jarrogan and mystery showed that you
know with high probability they could
estimate someone's sexual orientation
from their links on facebook
okay it's by virtue of your connections
and if some of your connection say
something about themselves and you know
so
um
so anyway so we need to do something
about this
um
and so
there's a notion of differential privacy
called no differential privacy
so
we say
that a given algorithm a
is epsilon no differentially private if
for all graphs g and g prime all graphs
that different at most one node so
that's the graph with or without bill
gates in it okay
or whether without me in it is what i
care about
um
and all events in the output space so
that algorithm might get
anything on the two graphs
putting me in or not in is only going to
make a one plus o epsilon
difference in the output okay
so you can't learn very much about me
okay you can't learn very much about my
income or my sexual orientation or
whatever
um
uh
from
uh from that so it's it's a it's a
well people
had
worked on edge privacy before which is a
much easier notion okay that says if you
remove an edge or you keep an edge in
what happens that's not really what i'm
worried about because i'm not an edge
i'm a no
okay
and so i don't care if you put my
you
know my edge to christian in or out
what's gonna happen it's you know
how about all the other ones right how
about there might be situations where
you really may not want people to know
that you actually have some context
but it's a much i mean the notion of can
i be in this network
and
people not be able to know things about
me is really the no notion so people
have worked on edge privacy and gems
graphs and stuff
so we used this idea in the proof called
the exponential mechanism
so what you want to do is
if
if this is the
the output what i want to do is i want
to be
generating
some
these
that are close to this
in what sounds close
well
uh you know again when i generated react
to go over all possible a whole possible
equivalence class of that 1b
and then
i want to generate according
exponentially and how far i am from that
okay
and
what we proved is so here we are bounded
it's much less than the other things we
talked about
if w is bounded if the corresponding
w which has generated these networks is
bounded
if the density is going to zero
and
here um
rho
not only
uh oh this should be n rho in no it's
okay no no no no because it's right
because rowan it's because i put the one
over in there i shouldn't have but
right so
uh
if if if m rho n is going to infinity at
least as fast as log n
so not just going to infinity but at
least as fast as
login
um
so in the first piece of work we got
upper bounds
and in second piece and not very good
lower bounds okay
no lower bounds and in the oh yes and
then
what we got with helios was that the
upper bounds match the minmax lower
bounds
in the limit of no privacy okay so we
have not
deteriorated
the estimates
as we go to no privacy okay
you might think that as we made
estimates we were doing
so badly that
in the limit of no privacy we would be
getting something worse
but we don't
okay and then
historic concept
our paper
showed how the privacy going to
infinitely power
this
oh go into infinity okay yes surprise i
mean
okay
no no
right so
you know the the question was how badly
have we missed
in the case of differential privacy from
the optimal stuff that you had gotten
and with with ilias we redid it so that
doing it differentially privacy with
differential parentheses
so for people for gnp
they upper and lower amount of how
private you can do it
they're off by effective spirit
so nobody knew how to and so they are
really astonished that they didn't know
if people didn't know it
so the upper bound in the case of
privacy
dependency up to some
locks
so for gnp you're not leaving either as
you would just say that i independent so
i estimate the edge density
and that is edge private and now you add
sort of edge noise to it
that that is actually the optimal edge
private ios
but it gives you a verb so this is
interestingly not the best algorithm if
you want notepads so you have to be much
more clever how you add noise into your
system if you want node privacy
and that if you do it right you get sort
of better by a square almost up to a
look and that's what elias really helped
us to do okay
so uh he's great he's your student right
foreign
student yes he was for a student uh that
was during an internship that he had
with us but we were really surprised
that it was possible to
to improve it that much um
okay
so now we've done this
and now
um
do i i guess i have a few minutes for an
application
okay um
okay okay
um so recommendation algorithm so um
you know
kind of
movies and people
you know for netflix or hulu
or amazon you know
products and people
whatever
um and i'm trying to estimate how much a
certain person is going to like a
certain product
okay or network completion
so i know that um a lot of economists
developmental economists they go they
measure some
uh network
but
you know from that they want to estimate
maybe
how you complete
that
right um
what other
uh connections are
you know likely to be there or not be
there based on sparse measurements
or network completion when you have
different kinds of things like
okay you know you don't only have
whether they're connected or not but how
they like each other or how much email
they send or
you know
how much they have commerce with each
other we sell things to each other
okay
so this is really a matrix completion
problem we have
people and we have movies and we have
ratings
between one and five but only very very
sparsely
okay
and so
how are we going to estimate that in the
same entry that i want to know
whether i i'm or you and then like you
know
some crazy movie
um
okay so all this is very learned about
it yesterday so for this whether this
graph is sparse all we have to do is we
have to use
do like dance all this could go for this
okay so you probably learned from
christian i don't know did you get to
the monday you know that although it's
kind of a cool generalization of
different eddies
two dimensions right um
and so
you know whereas definitely theorem you
know paul your iron and stuff oh it's so
surprising i can predict
if i condition on the density i can
predict all these things that i thought
were dependent on each other
so what aldous hoover says basically i i
like to view it this way if i view it as
kind of a
you know a late variable model
okay is that
exchangeability and organicity
lead to a latent variable model so
exchangeability the individuals we're
talking about
um
can be changed
okay um
and or forgot it
if we don't have a biggest maybe at
least that's the same one or god come
home so what all this hoover says
reinterpreted in the light of in using
the results of graph ones for dense
graphs is that if you have an infinite
dense array
of dependent
random variables
okay
which is which are exchangeable and
ergotic
then there is a feature space
okay
there is a set of attributes for example
such that if you condition on the
ergotic component and on the features of
all the vertices
the entries of the array are actually
independent of each other
and the distribution of those entries
depends only on the features okay so
that's kind of like the machine learning
view of
in terms of the metrics uh whatever
electrics is metrics are decomposed into
irregular components it is what you call
it
ah what is our body component then we
don't have
a probability of infinite random matrix
ah you're right and they're being
generated now
it's a polar to a poor probability
distribution you take some corners
or if you want you look at the things
which have a trivial sigma algebra
this respect geometric of i don't know
whatever on your probability spaces on
infinite right
probability space dangling on
i'm living in a finite space
no no this doesn't work so there's no
exchangeability theorem for finance
basis you need an infinite random matrix
and if in this mathematics setting
if you look at
blocks which physically don't overlap
yeah if their distribution is
independent
then this thing is ergonic okay forget
that there's a word carbonic which means
something
so so if that is independent
then you can model it within each one
even though these entries are
dependent
if i get right
if i fix on the right component then
i
write on one component then they're
effectively independent of each other i
mean that's a way of interpreting
all this hoover which i think is really
really cool actually and then the
distribution of them depends only on the
features so what this corollary says is
that
our matrix
which is the matrix of individuals and
the matrix and and movies
only depends on the features
and then these are independent random
variables which we can take to be
0 1 like
depends only on the movies and
and
the people even though a priori you
would think these are dependent on each
other but only through
those variables
so what this tells us is that this
y can be written as a function of
the people
and the movies
and some
random thing
which
i'm gonna say which i'm gonna
say to be okay i'm going to sample this
with probability okay i'm i'm i'm going
to sample
you and the movie with some probability
p which is small because i don't want to
look at all people in the world
okay
so
this is basically telling us we can
represent it by a w
okay
and then let d be the dimension of the
latent space and or the max dimension of
the two spaces okay the space of all
movies yeah is the probability
the same for all entries
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sample this so i give you
the output of a netflix has sampled
with some probability p which is very
small
you know in the
people putting in their votes let's say
is the same as sampling with
profitability
so imagine that there exists this
infinite matrix of rating every pair of
movies that users have
the pattern of the sentence is uniform
it's not doesn't it
okay so it could depend on the feet as
long as p is
if you scale it by something and once
you scale it it's up about it
then
it can depend on n
but it could in addition be multiplied
by a function which lies in zero one it
does depend on the features and it
wouldn't change
because you just may argue whether i
watch a movie or not really
so
um
given this observed data matrix why
can we learn
the expectation of why
and i mean this is stupid but you know i
could i could do this separately for
ratings one readings too
[Music]
trivial um
and ideally we would like to estimate
this for p
goes like one over n right i
i i want to know how to do this
if i haven't rated
um you know if i've if i've
redid on an average
you know uh not not too many of the
movies right
um so chatterjee um
his previous results required p
to go like
n to the minus two over d over two which
was not very useful for a large n and
large d i mean it was great that you got
some bound but one wants wanted to
improve that bound if you want to
uh
if if you want to apply it to real
situations where
you can't be reading that much okay um
or sampling that much if you're trying
to do a network completion problem or
whatever
okay so the challenge is varsity
challenge of sparsity is that you know
uh there there could be no no overlap
you know i
i want to use should be to
you know help
learn about what movies i might like oh
my god we've had no overlap in the
movies that we've watched
okay so what am i going to do and
obviously
something like this
um
so let's let's go on let's look at
expanding neighborhoods so i rated these
two movies these two movies
uh are also rated by some other people
those people have rated some movies
and
lo and behold i finally get some overlap
okay
so how far out do i have to go in these
expanding neighborhoods to have a
reasonable chance of an overlap
it's the birthday paradox
right how far how big is my class until
i'm going to have a someone else with
the same birthday right
and so the birthday paradox says that
you want the boundary to be greater than
square root of n
so how far out do i have to go to get a
boundary of that size
uh the radius has to be like log n over
log p n where p is the sampling density
because i have to have sampled it
okay
and then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to compare the product of
the ratings along the path
okay
and i do that basically with my graph
and so uh this is work with uh
christina
she was christina lee she's now
christina you
um and deborah rotcha
and so assuming that w
lipschitz
okay um and this is observed with some
probability that now it does go like one
over n although it has this nasty d
squared in front of it but still going
like one over n then the mean squared
error
goes to zero
pretty quickly okay
and uh
you know and if p is of this order so if
we give it
some logs then with high probability
this is going to happen
so it's much better than the previous
result which which was great at the time
which
could only handle this allows for
general noise and that kind of thing
which you're going to find if you're
trying to estimate graphics okay so
dense graphs metric
so
um okay so christian told you about all
these notions of convergence for sparse
unbounded degree graphs we need new
notions of inner of integrability like
uniform upper regular sparse graphs to
make sure those things don't
go off to infinity uniform tail
regularity and make sure that mass isn't
leaking out
and the second notion can be extended to
give compactness and subsequent
convergence without the assumption of
uniform tail regularity if you complete
this basic reference which
i'll do in the carp lecture
then we have these non-parametric models
these inhomogeneous random graphs
um and the graph on processes very
different
um two two nice ways of doing it
we can consistently estimate very
general unbounded sparse degree power
log a power log graphs corresponding to
an unbounded w
w has to be an l2
and we can consistently and
differentially privately
estimate these for a bounded w with our
results reducing to your results as the
privacy goes to your mid max
lower back okay
um
[Music]
and under the assumption of an
underlying latent graphon model we can
decide
design new approved matrix algorithms
thank you so much
any comments questions
questions
is just you look at churches various
false metrics so you're asking for the
differential parentheses
the marginalization matrix
matrix
and you essentially take it to higher
and higher powers
and actually so if you think it into the
graph i have a sparse matrix i
essentially pull out sort of this
effectively a branching process of
slightly diverted degrees
and then i take the transpose of the
matrix and that's the base you always do
like an operator like you would expand
and operate
yes
and multiply matches this until
the versace matrix is dense
and now i have and now i consider
so now i have a feature so i let's say i
have on one set of users
i change the matrix to the path so i do
a a transport a transpose and so on
and then the feature of the user i
is the vector of enters you see after
having multiplied the match it's often
enough
which will be dense so therefore if i
now look at my feature new features i
start to have overlap in this vector
space and i call them similar
if they are near in that space of
vectors
oh you want to know how long it takes
well you
internal position
so that actually gives the bones which
are
it's known to be optimal but this one
so this but this can't be
so it's
just in general you need some assumption
on sort of the brain of your i mean
uh
yes what does the legends have to be
actually do we know that
you take an underlying dense matrix
and
right then you generate a matrix that's
not right yet sure but i'm
yes
but then you put error on top of it so
it's maybe so it's ranked d plus
perturbation
it may work also there's some results of
human rights
okay we should discuss would be really
right so so maybe there's some general
algorithm
which goes fast
well
little no minimization goes fast
reasonable size
but you get the medical
structuralization algorithms
yeah and let everybody go to labor day
so here we have a rank d
object right you could instead have a d
by d stochastic block model which
generates it
and then for that we know so this
algorithm was actually developed by uh
standard for that case
we also know that belief propagation
works
we know that spectral works if you cut
off the launch decrease
and we know that the non-backtracking
matrix works
maybe they're already working
it's not equipped with it
it works
questions let's mention again
we didn't know it was our anniversary i
woke up this morning to my aunt uh
having
texted us i
always forget
just